[S01] 你试着想象一下这个场景啊
[S01] 那是1997 年
[S01] 在网络创世纪
[S01] 呃就是一款非常古老的网络游戏的开发过程中
[S01] 程序员在代码里意外打碎了一块承载着整个虚拟世界的魔法水晶
[S02] 对，这其实是个很有名的极客圈子里的轶事了
[S01] 是的
[S01] 为了让游戏能容纳众多玩家呢
[S01] 他们被迫将这块水晶的碎片分散到了不同的服务器上
[S01] 每一个碎片就运行着这个虚拟世界的一个独立部分
[S02] 他们当时大概完全没有意识到
[S02] 这个有点儿
[S02] 呃有点儿被迫为之的极客举动
[S02] 几乎构成了今天所有千万级并发应用能够存活的基石
[S01] 没错
[S01] 所以在我们今天的这项深度探讨任务里
[S01] 我们就要来拆解一下这本分布式系统领域的圣经
[S01] 《设计数据密集型应用》
[S01] 也就是大家常说的 DDIAA的第七章：分片
[S01] 我们要弄清楚
[S01] 当几亿人同时刷新时间线的时候
[S01] 数据底层到底发生了什么
[S01] 好的
[S01] 让我们来拆解一下
[S02] 嗯
[S02] 支撑现代互联网不坑牌的核心机制
[S02] 确实充满了这种
[S02] 怎么说呢
[S02] 在极限压力下逼出来的工程美学
[S02] 资料里提到了一句非常经典的话
[S02] 是计算机先驱格雷斯赫北在一九六二年说的
[S02] 他说
[S02] 我们必须跳出顺序computer指令的窠臼
[S02] 我们必须叙述关系而不是过程
[S01] 十九六二年
[S01] 哇
[S01] 那时候连互联网的影子都还没有吧
[S02] 对对对
[S02] 半个多世纪前
[S02] 它其实就已经预见到了单点计算的物理极限
[S02] 而所谓的分片
[S02] 也就是Sharding
[S02] 本质上就是我们为了突破这种物理极限
[S02] 对数据关系进行了一次
[S02] 非常暴力但又极其精密的重构
[S01] 呃
[S01] 提到物理极限
[S01] 我得在这里抛出一个可能很多人都有的疑问
[S01] 现在的硬件发展
[S01] 那简直是怪物级别的
[S01] 比如你在AWS或者阿里云上
[S01] 随手就能拉起一台有几TB内存
[S01] 上百个核心的超级服务器
[S01] 它的吞吐量已经恐怖到了极点
[S02] 确实
[S02] 单机性能现在非常强悍
[S01] 对吧
[S01] 就像是你的行李太重了
[S01] 你完全可以花大价钱去买一个特制的超级大背包
[S01] 这就是垂直扩展
[S01] 那为什么
[S01] 为什么非要雇十个人
[S01] 把东西分摊装进十个小背包里
[S01] 也就是水平扩展
[S01] 分布式系统意味着我们要去处理那种让人抓狂的
[S01] 网络延迟啊
[S01] 节点宕机啊
[S01] 引入分片这种重型武器
[S01] 它带来的复杂度和收益真的成正比吗
[S02] 这个是一个非常核心的质疑
[S02] 纯粹从算力峰值角度来看呢
[S02] 很多中型应用
[S02] 其实靠一台现代的大型云服务器
[S02] 真的就能跑满全场了
[S02] 但这里最引人肃胜的是
[S02] 分片的动机早就超越了单纯的性能或者容量
[S01] 哦
[S01] 不单单是为了性能
[S02] 对
[S02] 当我们把目光转向现在极其普遍的SAS架构
[S02] 也就是多租户场景的时候
[S02] 分片提供了一种单机永远无法实现的东西
[S02] 那就是
[S02] 硬隔离
[S01] 硬隔离
[S01] 呃你的意思是
[S01] 防范那些
[S01] 在系统里过度消耗资源的客户
[S02] 没错
[S02] 可以这么理解
[S02] 你想象一下
[S02] 假设你运用这一个企业协作平台
[S02] 后台就是一张巨大的单体数据库表
[S02] 你的客户里面呢
[S02] 既有只有十几个人的初创团队
[S02] 也有那种几万名员工的跨国巨头
[S01] 嗯
[S01] 体量超级极大
[S02] 对
[S02] 那如果这家跨国巨头
[S02] 在周一早晨突然跑了一个极其复杂的全局数据报表
[S01] 这个查询可能会瞬间吃掉数据库百分之九十的CPU和内存
[S01] 哇
[S01] 那就惨了
[S01] 那个十几个人的初创团队
[S01] 可能连发一条简单的文字消息
[S01] 都会一直转圈圈
[S01] 直接超时报错了
[S02] 没错
[S02] 在单体架构下
[S02] 所有的租户共享同一个资源池
[S02] 这就是典型的吵闹的邻居效应
[S01] 原来如此
[S01] 所以
[S01] 如果我们将数据进行分片
[S01] 就可以把这种超级大客户
[S01] 单独隔离开来
[S01] 甚至
[S01] 就是在物理层面上
[S01] 直接分配专属的服务器集群给这些特定分片
[S02] 是的
[S02] 大客户的报表怎么折腾
[S02] 也只会压榨他们自己所在分片的算力
[S02] 初创团队在另一个分片里
[S02] 依然可以享受毫秒级的丝滑体验
[S02] 而且更进一步说
[S02] 这还涉及到系统的容灾和合规性
[S01] 合规性
[S01] 这个怎么讲
[S02] 资料里提到了基于单元的架构
[S02] 你可以把某些分片的数据
[S02] 完全封装在一个独立的物理可用区里
[S02] 如果某个机房的光缆突然被挖断了
[S02] 只有分配到那个机房的租户会受影响
[S01] 也就是所谓的销售爆炸半径对吧
[S02] 对
[S02] 另外像GDPR这种极其严格的隐私法规
[S02] 它要求你必须能够彻底物理销毁特定用户的数据
[S02] 如果你所有客户的数据都纠缠在一块连续的磁盘扇区里
[S02] 彻底清理简直是噩梦
[S01] 呃但如果是基于分片的话
[S01] 就可以直接把那个对应的存储卷下线或者查除
[S01] 干脆利落
[S02] 完全正确
[S02] 所以你下一次在用企业邮箱或者各种SAS工具的时候
[S02] 其实底层都在用这些分片隔离机制来保护你的数据
[S01] 既然分片能带来资源隔离
[S01] 容灾控制
[S01] 还能提升吞吐量
[S01] 那摆在我们面前的第一个工程难题就是
[S01] 这蛋糕到底怎么切
[S01] 按照什么规则来分
[S01] 才能保证极其公平
[S01] 不至于产生那种
[S01] 焊的焊死烙的烙死的
[S01] 偏斜现象呢
[S02] 最符合人类直觉的切法呢
[S02] 叫做见范围分片
[S02] 这就好比一本传统的纸质百科全书
[S01] 呃就像第一卷是首字母A到B
[S01] 第二卷是C到D这样
[S02] 对对对
[S02] 在数据库里
[S02] 如果主键是用户名
[S02] 系统可以非常轻松的把字母表切分成几个段落
[S02] 然后分配给不同的节点
[S02] 对于范围查询来说
[S02] 这种切法绝对是天然友好的
[S01] 嗯
[S01] 如果我想找名字从A到C的所有用户信息
[S01] 系统直接去前面两个分片
[S01] 顺着磁盘扫一遍就全带回来了
[S01] 但是
[S01] 等等
[S01] 我发现一个漏洞
[S01] 如果这是一张sensor网络的数据表呢
[S01] 大家的主键不是名字
[S01] 而是时间戳
[S02] 哎
[S02] 你抓到重点了
[S01] 对吧
[S01] 那所有今天产生的新数据
[S01] 它们的时间戳
[S01] 全都是今天的日期
[S01] 这就意味着
[S01] 代表昨天
[S01] 前天的那些分片服务器
[S01] 现在全都在喝茶摸鱼
[S01] 而所有新来的上入的请求
[S01] 全挤在代表今天的那一卷里
[S01] 那个节点岂不是要被挤爆了
[S02] 非常敏锐
[S02] 这就是见范围分片最致命的弱点
[S02] 热点问题
[S02] 连续的高并发入写一旦集中
[S02] 几百台集群的集群瞬间就退化成了单机系统
[S01] 所以为了打破这种时间的连续性
[S01] 架构师们引入了哈希分片
[S02] 哦
[S02] 哈希分片
[S02] 就是用数学的方法把规律的数据打散
[S01] 没错
[S01] 我们不再直接用时间戳
[S01] 而是把时间戳喂给一个像MD五或者M二三这样的哈希函数
[S01] 哈希函数有个神奇的雪崩效应
[S01] 哪怕输入只差了一点点
[S01] 比如十二点零一分和十二点零二分
[S01] 输出的哈希值也会在整个数字空间里发生天翻地覆的随机跳跃
[S02] 哇
[S02] 所以十二点零一分的数据去了节点A
[S02] 一秒钟后的数据可能直接飞到了节点Z
[S02] 原本潮水一样涌来的数据
[S02] 就被均匀的轰炸到了集群的每一个角落
[S02] 大家终于都不摸鱼了
[S01] 是的
[S01] 写入牙里完美打散
[S01] 但是
[S01] 如果我们将这一点与更大的途径联系起来看
[S01] 架构设计永远是在做权衡
[S01] 哈希分片亲手扼杀了一个功能
[S01] 那就是我们刚才说的范围查询
[S02] 哎
[S02] 对哦
[S02] 因为数据完全水举了
[S02] 如果我现在要查
[S02] 今天下午一点到二点间的所有数据
[S02] 根本不知道去哪个节点找
[S02] 没错
[S02] 系统并无选择
[S02] 只能向整个集群所有的节点同时发送请求
[S02] 这就变成了极其低效的分散收集操作
[S02] 但这还不是最极端的
[S02] 因为这里才是真正有趣的地方
[S02] 即便有了哈希
[S02] 人类社会的极端行为依然会打破系统的平衡
[S01] 贾斯丁比伯引发的服务器风暴
[S02] 对，资料里这个案例非常经典
[S02] 在社交网络里
[S02] 像比伯这种拥有几百万甚至几千万粉丝的超级节点
[S02] 他随便发一句早安
[S02] 几分钟内就是上百万次点赞
[S01] 这个时候哈希也救不了命了
[S01] 因为这几百万个请求操作的都是同一个帖子ID
[S01] 无论怎么算哈希
[S01] 结果都指向同一台服务器
[S02] 没错
[S02] 听说在某些平台上
[S02] 这种单一账号的极端热点
[S02] 曾经一度吞噬了整个集群百分之三的算力
[S02] 这就是极端倾斜
[S01] 那系统工程师怎么反击呢
[S01] 面对比伯这种超级热点
[S02] 应用层的巧妙解法是加盐或者叫键拼接
[S02] 既然底层认死理
[S02] 同样的键只能去同一个节点
[S02] 那我们就在应用层
[S02] 在这个帖子ID前后人为的加上了两位的随机数
[S02] 比如从零零到九九
[S01] 呃这就像是为
[S01] 比伯的粉丝特设了一百个不同的结账通道来分流人群
[S01] 粉丝的点赞被随机分配到了这一百个新造出来的件上
[S02] 对
[S02] 这就把压力均匀分摊到了一百台机器上
[S01] 但但是等等
[S01] 结账是快了
[S01] 那如果前端页面现在需要实时显示比伯这条帖子的总点赞数
[S01] 我们要怎么读数据
[S02] 哎
[S02] 这就必须要付出代价了
[S02] 读取的时候
[S02] 系统就必须向这一百个子键分别发送请求
[S02] 然后把拿到的一百个结果合并起来
[S01] 为了拯救一台快要被写爆的服务器
[S01] 我们硬生生增加了系统的记账成本
[S01] 所以这种特殊待遇
[S01] 通常只能留给极少数的超级大V
[S02] 是的
[S02] 那随着数据继续增长
[S02] 不可避免地
[S02] 我们需要加SOVER
[S02] 这就引出了一个非常核心的问题
[S02] 怎么把旧数据平滑的搬到新机制上
[S02] 也就是再平衡机制
[S01] 这个问题我以前想过
[S01] 最直接的做法难道不是把哈希值除以节点总数
[S01] 然后取余数吗
[S01] 比如十二除以十
[S01] 余二就放二号节点
[S02] 这是一个极其繁殖觉的陷阱
[S02] 单次计算没问题
[S02] 但如果你加了一台机器
[S02] 节点总数从十变成了十一
[S02] 除数变了
[S01] 啊
[S01] 天呐
[S01] 十二除以十一的余数变成了一
[S01] 那也就是所有数据的余数全变了
[S01] 几乎全网的数据都要大搬家
[S02] 没错
[S02] 整个网络带宽瞬间被榨干
[S02] 系统直接瘫痪
[S02] 所以更好的策略是
[S02] 固定数量的分片
[S01] 固定数量
[S01] 就是虚拟的分片吗
[S02] 对
[S02] 假设我们一上来就划定一千个固定分片
[S02] 如果有十台机器
[S02] 每台就托管一百个分片
[S02] 当第十一台机器加入时
[S02] 它只需要向老机器要几个完整的分片过来就行了
[S02] 完全不用拆开重新算哈希
[S01] 原来如此
[S01] 搬家就变成了搬箱子
[S01] 而不是把箱子里的东西全导出来重新分
[S01] 那既然现在的云服务这么发达
[S01] 系统自动侦测负载
[S01] 然后全自动驾驶
[S01] 自己移动这些箱子
[S01] 岂不是最完美的呢
[S02] 嗯
[S02] 这就引出了一个非常重要
[S02] 也是极其严肃的问题
[S02] 完全的自动化
[S02] 有时候反而会带来无法预测的灾难
[S02] 也就是所谓的级连故障
[S01] 级连故障
[S01] 怎么发生的
[S02] 在分布式系统里
[S02] 你其实很难判定一个节点是不是真的死的
[S02] 可能某个节点只是因为刚好在处理一个复杂的查询
[S02] 响应慢了半拍
[S01] 但是其他节点误以为它挂了
[S02] 对
[S02] 其他节点一想
[S02] 哎呀它死了
[S02] 赶紧把它的负载接管过来
[S02] 结果大量的请求瞬间涌向其他节点
[S02] 把原本正常的节点也压垮了
[S01] 然后接着又压垮下一批节点
[S01] 像多米诺骨牌一样雪崩了
[S02] 完全正确
[S02] 所以对于移动分片这种沉重的操作
[S02] 适度的人工干预
[S02] 也就是保留一个确认按钮
[S02] 往往是防止系统全军覆没的安全法
[S01] 宁愿让它稍微笨一点
[S01] 那在日常运行的时候
[S01] 客端端是怎么在茫茫大海里找到正确的IP地址的呢
[S02] 这就要靠Zookeeper这样的协调服务
[S02] 或者是像Cassandra里用到的留言协议
[S02] 也就是Gossip
[S01] 留言协议
[S01] 听起来像是在办公室里传播八卦
[S02] 这个比喻非常贴切
[S02] 就是每个节点随机挑几个其他节点
[S02] 互相交换自己所知道的集群状态
[S02] 一传十
[S02] 十传百
[S02] 几秒钟内
[S02] 全网就都知道哪个分片在哪台机器上了
[S01] 哇
[S01] 没有中央指挥
[S01] 全靠大家私下八卦来达成共识
[S01] 这太奇妙了
[S01] 不过
[S01] 到目前为止
[S01] 我们全都在讨论按照主键
[S01] 比如ID来找数据
[S01] 但是
[S01] 如果我们不用ID找呢
[S02] 你说二级索引
[S01] 对啊
[S01] 假设你正在使用一个二手车网站
[S01] 汽车数据已经按照车辆ID分片了
[S01] 但现在
[S01] 你想找一辆红色的车
[S01] 这是二级索引
[S01] 这时候我们要去哪儿找
[S01] 整个系统完全不知道这辆车在哪儿啊
[S02] 寻找二手红汽车的难题
[S02] 这是分片里的硬骨头
[S02] 架构师只能在两种策略里选一种
[S02] 第一种是本地二级索引
[S02] 也叫分散收集模式
[S01] 也就是每个分片只管自己的一亩三分地
[S02] 对
[S02] 所以为了找红车
[S02] 系统必须去敲开每一个分片的大门
[S02] 问
[S02] 你这里有红车吗
[S02] 然后把结果收集起来
[S01] 写入的时候虽然简单
[S01] 但查询不仅慢
[S01] 而且容易产生长尾连迟吧
[S01] 只要有一个节点慢了
[S01] 我整个查询就得等着它
[S02] 没错
[S02] 所以有了第二种选择
[S02] 全局二级索引
[S02] 建立一个全局的索引局
[S02] 把红色统统归到某一个特定的分片上
[S01] 这样读取的时候只要查这一个分片就行了
[S01] 但是
[S01] 呃代价是
[S01] 每次有卖家上架一辆新的红色汽车
[S01] 后台可能就要跨越多个分片去更新索引
[S02] 完全正确
[S02] 而且为了保证数据不错乱
[S02] 系统可能需要动用非常复杂的分布式事务
[S02] 所以你看
[S02] 这就是分片的本质
[S02] 没有完美的方案
[S02] 永远是在权衡
[S01] 那么这一切到底意味着什么呢
[S01] 我们回顾一下
[S01] 分片它绝对不是什么魔法
[S01] 而是一套极致的拆解和协调的艺术
[S01] 从见范围到哈希
[S01] 从应对比伯这样的热点
[S01] 到二手红车的二级索引
[S01] 本质上我们都是在可伸缩性
[S01] 查询效率和系统复杂性这个不可能三角里寻找平衡
[S02] 是的
[S02] 也给我留下了最后一个非常挑衅性的思考
[S02] 你看
[S02] 我们将庞大的数据系统切割成分片
[S02] 用像Zookeeper或者流连协议来协调
[S02] 在热点出现时打散重组
[S02] 甚至还需要加入人工干预的规则
[S02] 来防止雪崩
[S02] 既然机器系统都需要通过如此精妙的规则来分权
[S02] 制衡和再平同
[S01] 嗯哼
[S02] 那对于我们人类社会
[S02] 日益膨胀的超大型公司组织
[S02] 甚至未来的去中心化社会结构
[S02] 这难道不是一种极其相似的生存法则吗
[S01] 如果一个社会系统大到单点无法承受
[S01] 我们该如何设计它的社会学哈希函数呢
[S01] 这真的是一个非常深刻的问题
[S01] 那今天非常感谢大家的收听
[S01] 下一次你在电商网站选上商品
[S01] 或者在社交媒体上刷新热搜的时候
[S01] 希望你能想起这些在后台默默运转的分片魔法
[S01] 保持你的好奇心
[S01] 我们下次来见